corporations for example
right we humans decided to create
corporations because
can benefit us greatly now all of a
sudden there's a supermarket i can go
buy food there i don't have to hunt
awesome and then to
make sure that this corporation would do
things that were good for us and not bad
for us
we created institutions to keep them in
check like
if the local supermarket sells poisonous
food
then those
some the owners of a supermarket have to
spend some years reflecting
behind bars right so we created
incentives to get
align them but of course just like we
were able to see through this thing
and you develop birth control if you're
powerful corporation you also have an
incentive to try to hack
the institutions that are supposed to
govern you because you ultimately as a
corporation have an incentive to
maximize your profit
just like you have an incentive to
maximize the enjoyment your brain has
not for your genes so if they can figure
out a way of
of bribing regulators then they're going
to do that
in the u.s we kind of caught on to that
and made laws against corruption and
bribery
uh then in the late 1800s
uh teddy roosevelt realized that no we
were still being kind of hacked because
the massachusetts railroad companies had
like a bigger budget than
the state of massachusetts and they were
doing a lot of very
corrupt stuff so he did the whole trust
busting thing to try to align
these other non-human entities the
companies again more with
the incentives of americans as a whole
um
it's not surprising though that you know
this is a value you have to keep
fighting
now we have even larger companies than
we ever had before
and of course they're going to try to
again
support the institutions
not because you know i think people make
a mistake of getting all too
um black thinking about things in terms
of good and evil
like arguing about whether corporations
are good or evil or whether
robots are good or evil a robot
isn't good or evil it's tool and you can
use it for great things like robotic
surgery or
for bad things and a corporation also is
a tool of course
and if you have good incentives to the
corporation it'll do great things like
start a hospital or a grocery store
if you have any bad incentives then it's
going to start maybe
marketing addictive drugs to people and
you'll have an opioid epidemic right
it's all about i don't want we should we
not make the mistake of getting into
some sort of fairy tale good evil thing
about
corporations or robots we should focus
on putting the right incentives in place
my optimistic vision is that if we can
do that you know
then we can really get good things we're
not doing so great with that right now
either on ai i think or on other
intelligent non-human entities like big
companies like we just have a new um
secretary of defense who's going to
start up now in
in the biden administration who is was
an active member of the board
of raytheon for example yeah so you know
i have nothing against raytheon i'm all
i'm not a pacifist but there's a obvious
conflict of interest
if someone is in the job where they
decide
who's they're going to contract with and
i think somehow
we have uh maybe we need another teddy
roosevelt to come along again
and say hey you know we want what's good
for all americans
and we need to go do some serious
realigning again of the incentives that
we're giving
to these big companies and
then we're going to be better off
you